[Music]
hello time for the press preview
then the first look at what is on the
front pages as they come into us here at
sky coming up we'll
check out the headlines with creera
political editor of the daily mirror and
harry cole political editor
of the sun we'll chat to you in a moment
first of all let's take a look at some
of those front pages for you we'll start
with the ft
this evening leading with the story on
sajid javid's call to learn to live
with the coronavirus bring it on
says the daily mail referring to mr
javid's vow to
end lockdown restrictions well the eye
is also leading on the new health
secretary and his ambition to end
restrictions on the 19th of july
and the daily express also leading on
the end of lockdown restrictions
labeling
sajid javid mr optimism
now boris rewrites history the metro
leads with the pm's suggestion that he
did
in fact sack matt hancock and the daily
star also leading with boris's
conflicting story on the departure of
mr hancock the guardian says ministers
are expected to announce an end to
isolation rules for pupils in england
and the telegraph highlights calls to
end self-isolation and social bubbles
for
children in schools let's slide in the
times
saying pupils face a mobile phone ban to
end
classroom distractions
and the sun leads on some gentle
encouragement for harry kane head of
england's
euros match against germany
and i'm joined tonight by pippa creole
political editor of the daily mirror and
harry cole political editor
of the sun great to see you both this
evening thank you very much for
for being with us this monday evening i
know you were watching the football
harry we've dragged you away from it
haven't we um
let's start shall we with the uh the
guardian then in fact the guardian
telegraph
both majoring on this story tonight
um pippa ministers to end isolation for
peoples
in england i mean for a few days indeed
a few weeks now there have been lots of
rumblings that the
the whole system of bubbling in schools
and and children having to be
sent home simply isn't working anymore
and it's almost getting out of hand and
i don't know about you but as a parent
i'm getting emails from the school
pretty much every day and you sort of
dread opening the email
in case your kids are the latest to be
sent home
yes i've got three children and touch
wood none of them have yet been sent
home this time
self self-isolate but pretty much all
their friends have and we also had
those emails from school so anecdotally
anybody that's a parent or friends or
parents is
clearly aware that this rise in cases
that we're seeing
the highest number of cases um than
we've had since
january i think it is at the moment uh
daily cases
is is basically predominantly amongst
young people and those who aren't yet
vaccinated
so it is hitting the young worse
obviously they're less affected by kovid
thankfully but um they are inevitably
being sent home and having to
self-isolate
i think there is uh suggestions in the
guardian that quarter million children
miss school in a single week this smart
this month
which is a huge number and when you
consider that kids are really amongst
those who have been
most disrupted um by this virus and
many of them really not spending as much
time in school as the parents and
as any of us would hope um it's had an
impact not just on education but their
mental health
and quite rightly and quite
understandably many parents and
now government are concerned about what
they're going to do about that going
forward
and whether they can introduce some
other system other than
forcing themselves isolate at home for
10 days and not to even leave the house
they're looking at according to the
guardian they're looking at bringing in
testing
for schools again in the way they did
when schools first went back in march
for the return of schools in the autumn
term which would make a big difference i
would definitely mean that children's
education was less disrupted
yeah harry also in this story in the
guardian
it mentions uh sajid javid who i think
had
had a pretty good debut in the commons
today by all accounts but he could anger
conservative backbenchers it says here
because he didn't rule out keeping
measures
such as masks and social distancing in
place in
in schools um and it has been this the
whole school's issue has become a real
problem hasn't it yeah no papers uh spot
on there
clearly it clearly isn't working and
you're right to say there has been
rumblings over
over the last few weeks and also we do
have this absolutely massive testing
capacity now
um not just a pcr test but the natural
flow tests are available
the the quick turnaround 20 minutes not
as accurate but still very quick results
um so it does feel like as part of the
great push towards freedom day of july
19th what a return
to what boris johnson described today as
as normal as possible
something slightly echoed by uh sajid
javid as well in his big debut
is you know some things have got to give
and obviously this
great big bubbling sweeping sweeping
classes out of school in and out
if there is testing capacity there why
not use it because we're not in the same
level of you know people
people's symptoms going for tests as we
were back in january february and march
so we might as well use this testing
capacity and you know try and get back
to as normal as possible
be right good day for senator javid i
don't think i think the guardian has
slightly played up the idea
that uh the tory mps will be annoyed
with him i think they were they he was
like
they had he had them like putty in their
hands today they you know he looked a
little bit like the cat that got the
cream in the end but
even the most swivel eyed of uh of
anti-lockdown slightly sort of uh
demented tory mps on the back benches um
weren't too happy what they heard he was
making all the right noises
but the problem was with this government
a little bit like boris johnson in the
run-up to
june 21st or june 17th whatever it was
um we're saying you know everything's
fine everything's fine we don't see
anything with the data not to do it
until about 48 hours before when they go
actually no we're not going to do it
but i do think the the the government
the government are investing a huge
amount of political capital now
in this july date and i do think if they
were trying to pitch role in any way to
roll back from it
they'd be they'd be making very
different noises than they are now so
they really are making their bed tonight
and lying in it yeah
we'll move on talk about more about uh
uh uh
um such a javi in a moment but just to
finish on on the school's pippa
um daily telegraph uh has got an
interview with the children's
commissioner as well she's clearly
extremely worried and i suppose the
problem for many parents is that there's
many of them now have had both jabs many
teachers have had both jabs
we know children aren't really that
badly affected when they do get covered
and i suppose many are saying well hang
on a minute we're going through all this
disruption kids are having to go through
yet more upset and trauma and actually
why are they doing this when the
vaccination program now is so successful
yes and of course the next big question
will be will children
be vaccinated and the jobs have been
approved by the regulators
the government many in government want
to crack on and do this particularly
in the department for education they
have obviously understand the
sort of the disruption that has occurred
for children
and there's a decision coming up soon by
the jcvi the body which
decides when and who gets the
vaccinations and there is some
suggestion
that certainly those aged 16 and over
could get the job at some point over the
summer holidays obviously that's the
exam cohorts at the top of secondary who
uh it would obviously benefit the most
directly being able to stay in school
and not have to go home and
learn you know via remote learning um
every few weeks
so um you know watch the space for that
but i think that's going to be
certainly going to be an interesting one
coming up in the weeks ahead yeah and
people will stay with you front page of
the daily mail
bring it on javid fights for freedom
harry's touched on
on his thoughts on uh the performance
today
of uh sanji javid but i mean what an
entree he's starting with
is he the right man for the job do you
think
he really does doesn't he i mean he's
certainly respected by his peers and
they
noticed more than one tory mp saying
that he's somebody who says
the same thing privately as he does
publicly which i think
many would regard as a welcome change
um uh from some of some of the you know
what we hear from government
but it was very very obvious and harry's
touched on this very striking change in
tone from him
i mean he's obviously much more of a
sort of cabinet hawk
than matt hancock his predecessor was
when it comes to lifting
lockdown restrictions it was always
hancock who seemed to be on the front
line urging caution
urging people not to go too far to sort
of make wise decisions some wouldn't i
say
ironically given some of the decisions
he's made himself but
um sajid javid is obviously somebody who
regards
july 19th as as the terminus state as
the prime minister has set out but that
is set in stone and he was suggesting
today that it was going to be
irreversible
that there's no going back but it's
dangerous that's dangerous for the
government as well because it sounds
very much like hostage fortune and if
they get to the point where
this rise in cases yes we're not seeing
um deaths resulting from this rising
cases thanks to the vaccine program
we get some more hospital data tomorrow
to see whether there's an impact
on hospitalizations but if it gets to
the point where
people are being affected very badly
because of the surgeon cases then
you know who knows maybe we could see if
there's a new variant for example coming
in
we could see restrictions brought back
in in future so it's quite
a big promise to make that there aren't
going to be any changes and this is
irreversible
and we have as how he mentioned been
here before with this government and the
public
i think wouldn't take too kindly to be
once again promised something
and then being told actually it wasn't
going to happen after all yeah
you mentioned mr hancock we'll talk more
about that after the break but harry
let's uh turn to the front of the
financial times javid shifts tone on
kerbs
in call for nation to learn to live with
kovid as people were saying uh
uh a real change in tone but the danger
is
uh isn't it that uh if he starts uh
talking about
uh dates rather than data
then it is sort of going back on what
the government has set up till now
yeah and i think this will be a really
interesting sort of battle to come
actually in the coming
hours and days really and we saw a
little overture of this yesterday
in the fact that you know as a cabinet
minister you're not just representing
your own views
you are also representing the views of
your department and the health secretary
is representing the views of the nhs
the views of the scientists the views of
the doctors um
so you know you sometimes always have to
park your own
sort of slightly libertarian streak
perhaps uh and
represent the views of of your
department everyone's talking about how
risky sunk was very bullish about
about lifting lockdown restrictions but
you know he was also representing the
treasury
he was also speaking on behalf of the
economic impacts and things like that
so it'd be really interesting to see how
it plays out for mr javed in the coming
days of whether he will be actually
slightly tempered
by the institution he's just walked into
he's pretty much worked in every
government department so far
except for health and it is a big you
know it is a big
institution and it has you know it is
bigger than one man it is bigger than
one's
secretary of state so be really
interested to see whether he slightly
tempers and tones it down a little bit
we saw his first little sort of skirmish
of that yesterday
when he arrived the department he did a
clip and it was very bullish about
getting back to normality as quickly as
possible
um and he was very optimistic very
upbeat about being able to do that
but then when the department for health
officials press released later on in the
day
what was meant to be his formal quote
they'd
literally gutted it and it was very
bland and it suggested actually and it
was you know
obviously we'd like to go back to normal
one day they removed all the optimism
out of it
and i just think this could be a really
interesting thing for sort of political
observers like pippa and i
there could be a really interesting
battle there because he's a very strong
world individual
um as he saw at the home office and
whether he comes up against the machine
could be quite spicy yeah because of
course the health secretary may have
changed but the advisors and the experts
and the and the mandarins
uh haven't uh and pippa just uh 30
seconds really before we take a break uh
front page of the eye 19th of july
end of the line for lockdown similar
theme but as labour's
john ashworth uh said today you know he
asked [ __ ] javid about
all the other things that he's got to
deal with cancer backlogs social care
reorganization of the nhs
um so and javid did talk about a fair
pay settlement didn't he for the nhs i
wonder if we're going to see a u-turn
there maybe
well this is coming up very soon the pay
review body is going to recommend to the
government what nurses in particular
has been concentrating on um are going
to get and
the nurses have reacted incredibly
angrily by
the suggestion that they get a one
percent p rise which is in fact a real
terms cut
so you know political mute music might
suggest if savage
comes into the new job and wants to kind
of get people on side that he might
decide that actually it'd be good
to um to increase that pay offer but
let's see what let's see what the review
body says because ultimately i think
it will come down to that okay thank you
both
for the moment plenty more still to come
as if harry kane needed
any more pressure this is the front of
the sun we'll have more on that in a
moment
[Music]
welcome back pippa and harry still with
us uh harry let's look at the front page
of the metro first time we've seen you
since that remarkable scoop by the sun
and of course it still rumbles on
now boris rewrites history um did the
prime minister
back or sack matt hancock then what are
your thoughts
well there's no doubt that there was an
effort to try and save matt hancock
uh last friday the government line was
this is a private matter that fell apart
pretty quickly once hancock realized he
was uh banged to rights as they say in
the trade um
they then tried to say oh well i'm sorry
i broke lockdown rules but then i think
overnight on friday i think probably
everyone slightly realized the level of
anger
was heading towards cummings levels of
barnard castle on speed really
and um i don't know who picked up the
phone who refers to who
but um you know i imagine by the time
that matt hancock
arrived at checkers um the the the the
writing was on the wall so shall we say
um so you know in the speed of
uh of political scandals you know 48
hours isn't massive
alison campbell was used to say you know
if if you're still on the front page
after 11 days
that's when it's when it's time to cut
the guy ropes so um
i think the inevitable result was uh the
writing was on the wall pretty early on
but
they got there in the end yeah it's an
interesting point paper isn't it um do
you think the hancock scandal will sort
of die away now as we approach july the
19th and people focus on that
i think boris johnson will hope so but
it was a spectacular attempt to try and
rewrite history the prime minister today
suggesting that he had in fact sacked
matt hancock and then number 10 saying
just minutes later that in fact it
hadn't been the case that he resigned
and i think
that raises questions about whether the
prime minister wants to lead the public
or
indeed be led by public opinion which
something he's grappled with in the past
and i think we'll continue to see but
yes jonathan i think you're right
i think a lot of the focus now going
forward once again roy johnson proving
himself very lucky
as a politician we'll be focusing on
july the 19th
and resumption of a more normal life as
restrictions are lifted yeah okay and
let's finish with the front of the sun
harry come on harry
even hancock scored is the cheeky
headline there um and we just heard
france knocked out
uh tonight lost on penalties to
switzerland uh just uh
very quick um ten seconds harry
i have to be very careful what i say my
french girlfriend is incredibly upset
right now
um but you know if we can beat the
germans tomorrow with the favorites the
french out
you know who knows what could happen
could be uh could be quite the summer
you